en teoría el gobierno de pedro casi o
venció su primera prueba de fuego ante
el parlamento al obtener el voto de
confianza el gabinete del primer
ministro guido bellido el mandatario
agradeció al congreso por otorgar el
respaldo político señaló que la búsqueda
de consensos permitirá la gobernabilidad
del país pero algunos ex congresistas
han afirmado que lo sucedido se trataría
de una estrategia del actual parlamento
para evitar que pedro castillo cierre al
congreso según la constitución peruana
si el legislativo niega el dos veces
consecutivas el voto de confianza al
gobierno el presidente tiene la facultad
constitucional para disolverlo por eso
los congresistas optaron por la
confianza pero esto no garantiza
relaciones de armonía y gobernabilidad
entre el congreso y el presidente pedro
casi o en los próximos días el
parlamento cítara a ministros del
gabinete bellido a sesiones de
interpelación y diversos congresistas ya
han adelantado que pedirán la
institución de algunos ministros por
poseer supuestos vínculos o
investigaciones por terrorismo nano
guerra garcía vocero de fuerza popular
partido de keiko fujimori ha señalado
que el actual gobierno habría elegido
quizás al gabinete más mediocre historia
republicana del país y que encontrará en
el fujimorismo a un muro de contención